[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMY UNRUH: Vertex AI is
an end-to-end platform
for machine learning
development and deployment.
It includes a suite of
new products and services
to support MLOps.
I'll introduce some
of the key pieces--
Vertex pipelines, feature
store, and model monitoring.
The backbone of the
Vertex MLOps story
is Vertex pipelines, which lets
you automate and orchestrate
your machine learning workflows.
Vertex pipelines is scalable,
serverless, and cost-effective,
and supports GCP standard
enterprise security controls.
You can focus on specifying
your pipelines without worrying
about infrastructure, and you
pay only for the resources
that you use.
When pipelines
execute, run metadata
is automatically logged.
This allows linage
tracking, reproducibility,
comparisons across runs,
metrics visualization, and more.
Let's take a quick look at how
these pipelines are defined.
Vertex pipeline supports two
easy-to-use Python STKs--
KFP and TFX.
Pipelines are built using
reusable components,
and many pre-built
components exist, including
those for Vertex AI services.
Here, we're building an auto ML
image classification workflow.
We'll just compile this
pipeline and run it right
from the notebook like this.
Then, we can view the running
pipeline in the console UI.
While the pipeline is running
or after it is finished,
you can view the pipeline
step logs and generated
artifacts and metadata.
And if you want to build
your own components,
this is easy to do as well.
Automating orchestration is not
the complete picture, though.
One common set of
pain points revolves
around feature engineering,
feature reuse and sharing,
serving features at scale
and with low latency,
and avoiding training
serving skew.
The Vertex feature store
helps solve these problems.
It reduces the cycle
time of ML deployments
by making it easy to share,
discover, and serve features
at scale.
After you've trained, evaluated,
and deployed your model,
you're not done.
You still need to pay
attention to the performance
of your model over time.
If model drift occurs, it
may be necessary to retrain
or tune the model.
Vertex model monitoring
helps with both alerting
and diagnosis.
You can set up a monitoring
job for a deployed model,
and get alerts when
there are anomalies.
You can configure monitoring
objectives for model features
and get distribution stats.
[MUSIC PLAYING]